we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p sometimes we
get political comments on the voicemail
line sometimes we get criticisms of the
program sometimes we get questions about
non political issues or topics and that
is exactly what we have today and it's a
question that i don't know that i'm
actually equipped to answer let's take a
listen to this - today's voicemail hey
David I was just wanting this question
actually can go to you or Pat or
actually both okay what is your favorite
Pokemon no thanks I I don't play Pokemon
and I don't have a pick favorite Pokemon
I did have the Pokemon Go app installed
on my phone for a couple months a couple
years ago and I thought that squirtle
was a funny name for a Pokemon but I
have no idea I don't I don't even
understand Pokemon you see more of like
a magic carpet Konig I read old dude
Magikarp Magikarp what is that a fishing
game it's the fish one oh now I don't
know that one yeah I like electro buzz
I like Geodude he's pretty cool MUC you
play these games on your phone no I
never played but I grew up with Pokemon
and I would have the crating cards and I
had the poster on my wall yeah oh wait
so Magikarp is a Pokemon yeah oh I
thought you were saying different game
I'm so clueless I don't know what the
hell is going on we should probably on
the show and look we should we please
let's delete the entire show and take it
from scratch because this is very very
embarrassing on the bonus show today we
will talk about Nancy Pelosi stalling
immigration talks with a marathon house
speech but does it really make sense to
do those Marathon House speeches does
anything actually get done as a result
will also talk about Trump had a very
weird hair day and a gust of wind blew
through and it created a lot of problems
and it's raising more let me put it this
way there's always been a lot of
questions about Trump's hair when the
gust of wind blew through Trump's hair
yesterday it created more questions than
the number of questions that were
answered and then lastly a Rob Porter
who was a was a white how to a twice
White House aide has resigned because of
allegations of domestic abuse and of
course that's also creating more quest
than the number that it's answering
including about elegant chief of staff
John Kelly all of those stories and more
on the bonus show two ways to sign up
david pakman.com slash membership and
patreon.com slash david pakman show
don't miss the bonus show